I haven't had time to talk about the art
of theater this
evening but theater is one of the places
like the other arts and philosophy that
our speech is our species goes to in
order to try to discover Beauty to try
to understand
itself to try to discover itself to
listen to beauty and to try as Roger
wrote to F the ineffable
in
1973 Lawrence Olivier appeared on the
Dick cavat show to discuss among other
things the opening of this country's
National Theater he also recited a
Shakespeare
sonnet and if anyone thinks that
television chat shows haven't dumbed
down in recent
years watch that
interview but the part of the interview
that I find most moving is this part
in which Olivier says uninterrupted and
with such easy
eloquence he's asked about the
importance of feta and Olivier
says I think feta is terribly important
I think that it is the initial
glamoriser of thought I think that
through the art of the theater can be
told without too much disguise but
without too much directness either the
secrets and thereby its antipathies and
and and sympathies the secrets and the
knowledge of the human
heart and I think that makes the art
makes the art of theater as important as
the doctor or the psychologist or the
minister even I think it's vitally
important that the world knows itself
and I think the theater is one of the
most immediate means of expression
towards that
end I'd like to say two things in
closing the first is that I learned a
lesson During the period in which I
defended sir Roger and it's a lesson I
should like to pass on especially to the
younger people present here
tonight please always stand up for your
friends especially when they're
right there is every reason reason in
the world to do
so but one is not obvious although
perhaps it should be and it's
this it might be the only chance you get
to show them how much they mean to
you if you don't seize this opportunity
whenever it comes
along you'll have to save the truth of
your feelings for their funeral or
obituaries it's not much use to anyone
then but if you defend if you if you
defend a friend while they're alive you
might just give them the slightest
intimation of how much you value them
and love them and how much other people
love them
too but I want also to say one final
thing in an era of cancellation and
defenestration we sometimes
forget that we cannot go on like this
and also that we've been here
before we know this because our greatest
writers and artists have addressed this
question in their own
times when Roger was going through his
own battle with the
shallows I often thought of
Shakespeare's rarely performed but great
play tyon of
Athens
timan has the whole world before him he
surr surounded by friends and
admirers he's been generous to
all yet he falls on Hard Times in the
city and when he
does absolutely everyone deserts him
he's left with nothing and nobody and
risks being filled with Despair and
rage it doesn't help that he's shadowed
by the cynical philosop philosopher aam
mantis who has warned him that just such
a desertion might one day
occur I adore this
scene and should like in closing to read
it but I'm not a professional actor so
I'd like to invite someone to the stage
who is the former Cameron Macintosh
professor of contemporary theater here
at Oxford one of the great actors of his
generation somebody I'm very proud to
call a friend Kevin
spacy
why why Dost thou seek me
out why Dost thou seek me out apam
mantis thou are a
fool whom Fortune's tender arm with
favor never clasped but bred a
dog a mangi
dog hat thou like us from our first
swath proceeded in the sweet degrees
that this brief world affords to such as
May the passive drugs of it freely
commend thou wouldst have plunge thyself
in general Riot melted down thy youth in
different beds of lust and never learned
the icy precepts of
respect but follow the sugared game
before thee
but
myself who had the world as my
confectionary the world the mouths the
tongues the eyes and the hearts of men
at Duty more than I could frame
employment
that
numberless upon me stuck as the leaves
do on the
Oak and have have with one Winter's
brush fallen from their boughs and left
me
open
naked for every storm that
blows I to bear
this that never knew but better is some
burden a burden thy nature did commence
in
sufferance
why should thou hate men they never
flattered thee used thee deceived thee
what hast thou given what hast thou ever
given hence be gone
gone if thou Hast not been born the
worst of men thou Hast been born a Nave
and
flatterer what would thou do with the
world Aus if it lay in thy
power what's the thy see thyself fall in
the confusion of men and remain a beast
with the
beasts a beastly ambition that the gods
do Grant thee to attain
to if th were the
lion the fox would beguile thee if thou
were a lamb the fox would eat thee if
thou were the fox the lion would suspect
thee when perchance thou Hast been
accused by the
ass and were thou the
ass thou wouldst be tormented by thy
dullness and still thou livest as a
breakfast to the
wolf and W thou a wolf thy greediness
would afflict thee and off thou should
Hazard thy life for thy
dinner W thou a
unicorn pride and wrath would confound
thee and of thou
shouldst Hazard thy life for thy
dinner were thou a
bear thou would be killed by the horse
were thou a horse thou would be seized
by the leopard were thou a leopard with
that were jine to the
lion all the spots of thy Kindred would
serve as jurors on thy life jurors on
thy
life and all thy safety were remotion
and all thy defense
absence what Beast couldst thou be that
were not subject to a
beast and what a beast thou are already
that see us not thy loss in
transformation away thou issue of a
mangy dog away thou tedious fool Beast
toad rogue rogue
rogue I am sick of this false world and
will love it
[Applause]
not